desean calls for the ball here's the
snap watson looking pocket collapsing
wants to try to get away he does to the
right throws to the end zone caught by
bells
magical
touchdown houston and the texans take
the lead
i think the officials have learned a
thing or two about when desean watson is
and isn't
in the grass right right because this
guy is incredible and he was twisted up
he got kicked in the face ultimately
comes out of that play to throw the
go-ahead touchdown texans win
27-24 over the oakland raiders come from
behind fashion the texans in the thick
of in the afc south everybody in the afc
south won yesterday
the colts the jaguars the titans the
texans all win
and deshaun watson is phenomenal and
chris
we were talking about deshawn watson
last night
and we were asked to describe him in a
word the video that we do in the third
quarter of the game after you're home in
bed yeah and uh my words underrated and
i still continue to believe that we do
not properly give deshaun watson as
media and fans the credit he deserves he
took the nfl by storm in 2017 he tore
the acl by 2018 when he was healed
we were all smitten with patrick mahomes
right we forgot about deshawn watson
yeah watson beat mahomes right this year
right watson is right there with mahomes
yeah we need to give and he's not
injured right now when mahomes is no i i
mean uh you know i hear you he is a
little underrated underappreciated for
what he's doing and if it wasn't for
patrick mahomes we would be going man we
haven't seen a young quarterback do this
in a long long time look at this guy
he's special we've never seen a guy like
this before so i do think that patrick
mahomes factor has you know hurt desean
watson's maybe overall public perception
that way but he is uh in the rarefied
group at least in my opinion of you know
him rogers ma holmes russell wilson
doesn't matter the situation who's hurt
who's healthy they're so good physically
and have such great physical skills that
he can overcome a lot with just that
even when the play caller's having a bad
day and watson i mean come on on the
touchdown to just show you the game is
like slow motion for him right now he's
going to spin around and do a whirly
bird put his hand on the ground get
kicked in the face and then have the
wherewithal to like oh let me straighten
out my face mask as i do this because i
don't see that good and then throw the
touchdown i mean this is unreal here we
go oh hey oh no no problem you're 270
pounds on my back i'll just spin around
and put a hand down and then when i do
that i'm going to just uh regain my
balance oh you want to kick me in the
face no problem let me fix my face mask
oh i'm falling oh big deal here's a dart
for a touchdown so much talking the last
week about a young quarterback seeing
ghosts desean watson is the ghost
right yes he makes defenses he goes
they're like which way did he go which
way did he go jj watts going to be a
different kind of ghost the rest of the
season he has done for the year for the
third time in four seasons and this
happened so fast straight to the
hospital after the game mri
torn peck he announced it on twitter
last night he's out for the year and it
just look as he pointed out the game can
be beautiful it can also be brutal it's
been brutal to him he never gets down he
never gets discouraged he'll he'll get
healed up and he'll be back and he'll
keep going and and that's the one thing
that i think we all need to appreciate
about nfl players
they spend so much time perfecting their
bodies and getting their bodies to the
point where they are completely healthy
and they are at their highest possible
level and then they put them out there
on a football field where they know
inevitably something's going to break
something's going to tear something's
going to bust and you've got to go back
to the lab and bust your butt again to
get back to the point where everything's
fine you're 100
peak physical condition right you go
back out there and you know what's going
to happen it's the lather rinse repeat
for the duration of your career yeah
that's right hey i'm feeling good again
it's time to go into some more car
crashes i can't wait this is gonna be
fun i mean that is kind of the attitude
of an nfl football player huge blow to
this texans football team i mean jjy is
still a phenomenal player is he you know
nfl defensive mvp type talent that he
was four or five you know years ago no
but he is unreal and this is a defense
too you know not a lot of playmakers in
the front seven that's where it really
hurts them their run defense good but
their past defense not and jj watts
ability to get to the quarterback is
gonna hurt now that he's not there but
they'll still be contenders because of
desean watson
way to button that up
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports